We have a voicemail number
That number is 219-2DAVIDP
This is a voicemail from someone we've been sort of speculating
what will ultimately
pull Trump's approval rating
really down further than the already record low numbers
that he's already experiencing
what will it take
for Republicians to say "we need Trump out".
Here's one caller
who had an idea about what it might take to ultimately turn those last
recalcitrant Trump supporters
against him.
"...(David) the only way we'll be able to get rid of Donnie [Donald Trump] is if the economy tanks"
"I know everybody's gonna suffer if the economy tanks but..."
that's the item that will let people up to his terrible, terrible presidency"
Yeah
Uh, I don't agree
I don't agree because
even when the economy tanks
You'll have a really good propaganda campaign
about how well things are going
We see it under every administration
Every administration
Democratic and Republician
Will make the case that the economy is doing okay
and George W. Bush...recall
George W. Bush was re-elected
during...not good
...really not good
(uh) economic circumstances
and although I would like to agree with the caller
that...again, it's this idea of once it hits you personally,
you will change your mind
I would like to agree with the caller
that if Donald Trump does start to tank the economy
and how we define that
well...there's different ways we would define that
people would abandon Trump...
...I don't believe they would
because there will be a narrative
that would come from the Trump administration
that *will* resonate with some significant portion of Trump supporters
and sadly like I said before
even with a 30% approval rating
Donald...Donald Trump could still be re-elected President of the United States
On the bonus show today
a 30-foot border wall prototype has been erected
in the San Diego border lands
we'll talk about that
There's a flyer that is suing an airline
because his champagne was not champagne but was rather just ordinary sparkling wine
Is the flyer
producer Pat, we will find out on the bonus show
and why Amazon's new 5 billion dollar headquarters might not be so good for the city that you live in
All of those stories and more
on today's bonus show
Davidpakman.com/membership
and patreon.com/davidpakmanshow
...so sign up and get instant access.